joining us now with reaction is Fox News
contributor and syndicated columnist
Arroyo Murdock and the author of direct
fire former Brigadier General Tony Tatum
all right general I'm going to ask you
since we were talking about that that
that video that supposedly shows an
intercontinental ballistic missile that
they say has Florida in the background
now aside from their ability to do this
and whether they have that are we
entering a new phase of a Cold War you
know I think we might be judged and and
I just like to back up and say that I
think President Trump just as he
unleashed us to defeat Isis has done
more to attack and and defend against
Russia than President Obama ever did and
then as we look at what the missile that
you know President Putin supposedly
showed the launch of that is you know
attacking the concept of mutual assured
destruction and what he wants to do is
to make sure that we feel uneasy about
our ability to fend against the the
weapons that Russia has and so we we
launched off a submarine a
intercontinental ballistic missile this
week and the Pacific Ocean so Russia
launches it's interesting well but it
sounds like a tit for tat again yeah
well it's very much and this is very
much the almost war by proxy that we had
in the Cold War as you mentioned at the
beginning of the segment and and this is
through the elements of powered
diplomatic information military economic
you see spies being fired you see
information Wars that's an information
PC they call it a spy spats right as I
was reading a dory you know all the talk
about the leptin you know how the
president has colluded although after
what 14 15 months nobody has one iota of
American evidence is this gonna hurt the
left in terms of the midterms with the
president being so tough on Russia and
not only that to worry is that he's got
23 countries NATO they're all backing
the president I mean who and when Obama
used to talk about it there was no one
behind him now
there is well the left has been
preaching this gospel for the last year
and a half or so that President Trump is
a puppet of Putin and he does whatever
Putin says and yet you've seen as you
said organizing this diplomatic effort
to remove these these diplomats from
around the world
just yesterday I think it was Poland
announced it was going to purchase about
five billion dollars in anti-missile
systems from the United States pointed a
Russia I'm sure Trump has provided
offensive weapons to Ukraine I think
about a month ago or so there was an
attack on 100 Russian mercenaries in
Syria they're now dead so if he's a
puppet of Putin he's not a very well
behaved one well you know there was talk
today about a two of our astronauts are
on a vessel on a Russian vessel that has
gone into I guess outer space the Soviet
soya I mean so is this all talk given
that you know everybody knows we've got
Americans on this Russian vessel or
whatever it's called well you know
that's what I was saying earlier judge
is that this is information warfare this
is the two countries posturing for power
in the power vacuum that was left by the
Obama administration before you know the
President Trump and his national
security strategy talks very much about
peer competitors China and Russia and as
I said he's done more to compete now
against China Russia North Korea than in
the previous administration and we've
got a trillion dollars worth of 30 years
of modernization of the nuclear weapon
arsenal that we've got that President
Trump has laid out so he's taken this
seriously and he's standing up to Russia
right and he's got he's got some force
behind his words but you know during
that you know Russia's acting like
they're the victims in this whole thing
you know that they didn't deserve to be
booted out but you know the deadly nerve
agent that was used that no one could
really you know I guess proved beyond a
reasonable doubt the daughter is now
talking she can I I imagine tell us how
the nerve agent was delivered who may
have delivered it who the last person
was that she saw things aren't looking
good for the Russians if
indeed it is as everyone is suggesting
the Russians who did this yeah I mean
we've had somebody who I guess the
Russians may have wanted to be a corpse
is now it turns out to be a witness and
she may be able to speak up and give
this exact kind of evidence you're
talking about I think it's also
fascinating that the this case in other
cases where people have been basically
assassinated by by Moscow that they
don't just use you know rat poison or
put a pillow over somebody's face
they're using the kinds of agents that
are tied back to Moscow is it almost as
if they want to leave their fingerprints
behind I wonder if that's something they
deliberately want to do maybe sending a
message to others rather than just
eliminating somebody who they find
inconvenient all right Dori Murdoch
general Teta thanks for being with us